Harry Roxburgh wants us to know if we  can his five cups of the table in a row  sure we can so that was fairly easy now  let's take it a step further and try ten  cups with me and Amy  [Applause]  Daniel in Z X challenges are stitute ten  back hand around the net shots in a row  [Music]  [Applause]  let the sensei so how's done  [Music]  so Geeta Gupta wants to put an apple on  one of our heads and shoot it down with  a ping-pong ball let's decide who has to  be the target  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  why bother try wants to play a rally of  20 while upside-down let's hope this  doesn't take too long  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Hey  thanks for watching guys if you enjoyed  it remember to give it a thumbs up until  next time